Turkey's president this morning accused
Saudi Arabia's government of planning
four days to have Washington Post
contributor Jamal Khashoggi murdered in
a speech to the Turkish Parliament this
morning he called Khashoggi x' killing
savage not an accident now as for the 18
suspects in the case to be tried by
Turkey the US has now sent CIA director
Gina Haswell to Turkey to help in this
investigation Holly Williams is an
Istanbul outside the Saudi consulate
where Khashoggi was killed Holly good
morning to you good morning president
Erdogan said the explanation that Jamal
has showed he was killed in a rogue
operation would not satisfy Turkey or
the international community and he
demanded to know who it was in Saudi
Arabia who sent the suspected killers to
Istanbul the Turkish president directly
contradicted Saudi Arabia's official
version of events the chamalla Schulte
died seemingly by accident after getting
into a fight inside the consulate but
the Saudi account had already been met
with skepticism and outright disbelief
this surveillance video broadcast by CNN
appears to show part of the Saudi
attempt to cover up her shock his death
this man is seen walking into the Saudi
consulate around two hours before her
show G entered the building and was then
killed later the same man emerges from
the consulate apparently dressed in her
shock geez clothes an effort it seems to
pretend her shocked G left the building
unharmed there's still no word on where
her shock jeeze body ended up now Saudi
officials have given CBS News a slightly
different story to explain her shock
geez death claiming he resisted after a
threat to kidnap him and was then put in
a chokehold to stop him from yelling
resulting again apparently accidentally
in his death we simply cannot know if
this is any closer to the truth on Saudi
state TV Treasury secretary Steve
minuchin was shown meeting with Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman who some
believe is more closely connected with
her Shah jees death than Saudi Arabia
will admit and president Trump's
son-in-law and advisor Jared Kushner
who's cultivated a close relationship
with the Saudi authorities stressed the
importance of America's ties with Saudi
Arabia right now as an administration
we're more in the fact-finding phase and
were obviously getting as many faxes as
we can from the different places and
then we'll determine which facts are
credible and what President Erdogan did
not mention today is a widely reported
audio recording that Turkish officials
allegedly possess of Jamal hisagi being
killed we still do not know if that
recording actually exists bianna
meantime Merida wants still pressing for
an independent investigation Holly
Williamson Turkey thank you